good evening I got a couple of hello
hello has anybody here actually played
around with Android or cutland in the
room a couple guys great this is
probably just going to be pretty basic
for you but I have to tell you as
somebody has who has done done it quite
a bit and untested differently it was
really interesting to discover the way
that things are done so I decided I
wanted to share this because I didn't
actually have the same kind of
experiences piecing this together as
what is usually now available you know
directly on unlike in the web site for
for Kotlin or for TDD in general I also
came from a proof-of-concept background
where we didn't write tests I know that
sounds terrible
but we actually had people who would
test for us so I don't have to worry
about that and and I don't know if all
of you ever came from that background
where you start up as a consultant and
you just want to get something built but
then I got put on a team most recently
that had this approach and I thought it
was kind of cool and I wanted to share
things that I liked about it and things
that I didn't like about it
so first those of you who do this all
the time this is probably just a little
bit more of a basic refresher for me it
was exciting to go through the process
of learning TDD what it really was so
this is about a little heavy on the TV a
little loud on the Kotlin because
luckily for us Colin makes it easy so
that's a little bit about what this is
about for those of you who don't know me
my name is Heather Downey I'm really
into innovation and enterprise level
stuff I like to do consumer facing
applications and some people know me as
a speaker so if you're interested at all
in additional things that I do you can
follow me at Coraline on Twitter alright
if you're interested in what we're gonna
cover today let me give you a little
overview all right
we are gonna kind of just go over the
kind of case study that I was given just
a real basic one
I had the original he said he completely
written out but sometimes the way that
it goes is that you're not allowed to
share some of those details because the
company doesn't want to sign off on him
and unfortunately for me they just
decided not to so instead I went ahead
and gave an example but I will kind of
just go into a little bit more detail
about the kinds of implementations that
we did I'll also give you a brief
introduction to test-driven development
because like I said that was one of the
things that I discovered during the
course of this application that we were
building and what is the difference
between TDD and behavior driven
development also a little introduction
to how Kotlin fits in to testing and
it's not Kotlin itself I don't go
through the whole language it's awesome
I'm gonna give you that as we're warning
but I just go specifically into how
Kotlin applies to testing and using TDD
in a proof of concept approach what we
think about that the coolest part of
this entire thing was my discovery of an
easy kind of five-step method of how to
approach TDD because until that time I
was very overwhelmed with how much extra
work it felt like and how much my brain
disliked it and we're gonna go into a
little bit of a collaborative game I
know there's not very many people but
hopefully you'll kind of interact a
little and some key takeaways so this is
what we're gonna cover today and this is
again quite interactive so anybody have
any questions before we start
yes No awesome
so I used to call them client objectives
this is a case study kind of about that
probably most of you in the room are on
a team yes is anybody here just on their
own like it sold it yeah well you are
awesome awesome have you ever been in a
team before though okay most companies
have a process of how they break down
the tasks we got to do this is not the
talk for that but most of us know it as
the agile process right it usually is
interpreted depending on how much you
need it but when I the reason I'm
putting that up
it's because this started from a place
of just a simple user story at first we
were just saying yeah we can build an
app in like four weeks five weeks six
weeks whatever it is but the amount of
time that we quote quite often has
nothing to do with thinking about the
testing we don't think about the
additional testing of a QA person you
know think about the testing of our
client let alone thinking of the test
before you write them right I was
thinking this is how long it would take
for me to implement this the problem
with giving a lot of just a ballpark
they I usually have a client engagement
person will kind of rope you into I'll
just give me a ballpark idea how long
that would take and so whatever you say
off-the-cuff is probably wrong you need
to double it and the triple it for good
measure and so when I tell Simon oh
implementing that screen I'll take me a
week what really the actual
implementation probably take a lot less
than that but because we have to iron
out all the details of what they really
want that's probably how long
realistically the entire process is
going to take okay so now we're kind of
up against this deadline where we signed
a contract and no we have to deliver it
week five whatever States in we deliver
it so I'm really interested in how we're
going to achieve this 100% test coverage
mystery in five weeks to me that's a lot
of extra work you know to be able to do
that not that testing isn't good
it's that how do we make sure that we
cover that so the way that the team that
I worked on approached it is that well
we just do everything TDD and I'm like
wow that's some not a lot of time for
that you sure we have time and I said oh
yeah eventually once you get good at it
you can build it in the same amount of
time so what I'm going to just kind of
walk you through is what actually
happened because again we all have
different holes in our backgrounds right
there's a lot of things that I know a
lot about that you probably don't and
vice versa my particular hole is that I
didn't ever follow the TDD way like I
had always just played around until
something got to work and then maybe I
would
a unit test later to make sure that we
had some test coverage for it but I had
never written tests first my brain
wasn't thinking that way my brain thinks
as an implementer right so a user story
that I get like day one kinda looks like
this as an administrator I want to be
able to create user accounts so I can
grant users access to the system this
should be what they call a small pointed
ticket and I'm like okay great
as the team that we were on was also an
XP shop that meant that more than one of
us would actually sit at the computer at
the time and work on this right there
was nothing else in the ticket except
for this so that's all they felt that
they needed to give us and I'm like oh I
think I have I think I understand the
basics here I can I can go from there
but because of the way that unity can
work it actually needed more acceptance
criteria it needed better acceptance
criteria so that basic statement started
being able to be broken down further and
further good acceptance criteria might
be a list like this if I'm an
administrator I can create user accounts
so right there that is one piece of it I
can create a user account by entering
the following information about the user
X Y Z I cannot assign a new user to
report to an inactive user oh that was
important to know I didn't know that now
I know that I cannot assign a new user
to report to a user if it recruits a
cyclic whole relationship like yeah
that's pretty self-explanatory and the
system notifies me that it sent an email
to the new users email address
containing the system generated initial
password and instructions for the person
to log in and change a password and I am
able to verify with the intended
recipient of the email that it was
received there's a lot more going on in
that ticket than I originally intended
so what is starting to happen
is that as a developer I have to ensure
I have good acceptance criteria or I
didn't work on a ticket that was new for
me because usually as developers we're
the last ones down the road after all
the decisions are made we're kind of
left holding the bag well we spent all
this time on design and hashing out what
we think it needs to be and okay now you
just need to hurry up and do it but by
approaching it this way what I was
fascinated to see is that I actually had
power to push back and say well we can't
write tests for this because I don't
have enough small chunks of acceptance
criteria so that I can do those things
and that was something I felt was very
beneficial because these are really easy
black and white things that a client can
say oh yeah I wasn't specific about that
and so the onus is not on you to deliver
like something that it was complete in
five weeks the onus is on them to give
us complete acceptance criteria if they
want something accurate so that was
something that was kind of like a side
thing that I really felt was valuable so
now that we have our good acceptance
criteria this is my first introduction
to TDD cool has ever been anybody in
here done TDD as an approach good couple
of you cool so come along with me I
didn't even really know what it was
no of course like everybody else I
started googling it basically you'd
write a failing test you make that test
pass and refactor like that it's that's
all it is
TDD can be defined as a programming
practice that instructs developers to
write new code only if an automated test
has failed so this avoids duplication of
code and TDD means test-driven
development
the primary goal of TDD is to make the
code clearer simple and bug free so this
is the intention behind this a lot of
people just refer to it as red green
refactor okay this was an interesting
concept to me because I've never written
something on purpose that doesn't work
okay
usually it's an accident so it was a
huge paradigm shift for my brain
my brain doesn't like it so I really
needed a little bit more of an example
of what that is
I needed some clarifications about TDD I
needed to know that
TDD is not about testing or about design
it's also not right some of the tests
and then build a system that passes the
tests it does not mean do lots of
testing so I was a little bit confused
as to exactly what kind of approach we
were supposed to do how far down the
minutiae did we need to go with all of
this it felt really overwhelming and the
only reason it felt overwhelming is
because I love building but this felt
like taking an exam all the time right I
felt like taking an exam and that kind
of took the joy out of it but then
something else was kind of introduced to
me as a concept it's that TDD gives you
confidence that what you have written
can be automatically tested and
completely covered no matter at what
point your budget runs out no matter
what point you have to hand it over you
know that you have tests for everything
and that is valuable production code and
I was like yeah but but if they didn't
get a whole system within that five
weeks is that valuable it's interesting
just to kind of mole of your head so I
started looking into TDD just a little
bit more and I just discovered an
interview with Robert Martin uncle Bob
about his three laws of TDD so that I
could think about the way to situate my
brain number one you are not allowed to
write any production code unless it is
to make a failing unit test pass and it
has to be in the smallest way so if you
write something to call a function that
you haven't written yet that fails so
that means the smallest amount of work
that you can do to make that pass is you
create a blank function that passes null
now the test passes
that was rich to me too that is like
writing the red test getting it to pass
and now we have to refactor that to
really be more of what we mean so that
means it's very very small very
incremental this actually worked really
well with some of our junior developers
who had to slow down and think in
smaller pieces absolutely
law number two you are not allowed to
write any more of a unit test than is
sufficient to fail and compilation
failures our failures also kind of blew
my mind a little bit and his third law
which is you are not allowed to write
any more production code than is
sufficient to pass the current failing
unit test so that means if you do
something with a new production code
that actually causes any sort of a
cascade effect you're only supposed to
do one at a time only fix one at a time
that and if you can't fix one at a time
that's an artifact of something that is
too tightly coupled so that promotes a
decoupled kind of system which of course
is something that we all want to get to
right we want to be able to swap out any
sort of calls that we're doing so now
that I'm a little more familiar with the
way to think about it how do I name all
of my tests right so there is a process
in place that many people use there's a
couple of different ones the one that
I'm going to show you is a given when
then anybody familiar with that yes a
couple of you okay for those who aren't
given is the preparation okay it's the
object that's under the test
initialization okay that's usually where
any of your stubs or mock creations of
your object will happen within your test
class and any injection of dependencies
okay it kind of looks like this given
user is logged in okay this would be the
beginning naming of your test given when
this happens when would be the execution
okay an operation to
test in a given test it could look like
one of those like when a user launches
the app or when the user clicks logout
okay then is the assertion okay this is
the important I'd argue part of this
test it processes the received result
and verifies any mocks that you have and
it might look like this then the user
sees the logged out text this is very
small right a very small test to me
there are additional frameworks that
some of their really major applications
companies have put together that
actually makes this a little bit easier
one of them is Shazam has anybody ever
used Shazam you know to listen to music
and it process it and tells you who the
artist is Shazam wrote their own test
framework in Kotlin so that they
actually could chain method calls that
makes it very easy to read kind of look
like this right I mean look at the
extension methods all the way down right
it's just an example of their helper
framework okay although that was pretty
cool but it's not something I can use
because it's proprietary to them so
really I needed to think about it in the
most basic what shifts of Kotlin way
which is kind of like whatever unit of
work the statement under the text and at
the expected behavior okay when really
if I wanted to let's say create a
password validator okay all I'm thinking
about is something that looks like this
right I just want a basic validation
method to me there is only one test
because there's only one method so all I
care about is what goes in and out right
much to my surprise looked more like
this so there really was like four tests
for that one function because there were
four different kinds of cases I can come
out of this and this can go on and on
there can be quite a bit you can only
test what you know you can only write
tests for what you know should or should
not occur right so as you go you may
additional tests for existing functions
also as QA does their job and discovers
things you have to add additional tests
blew my mind so instead of me writing
just that one one function now in my
brain I like wrote five but four of them
were tests right very different way to
think about it but if I change anything
in my function don't I want it to be
caught somewhere if my test mirror is my
function exactly then there's not a lot
of value in that there's not a lot of
changing if the what the data is that
goes in right
all of those test cases what is very
cool about Kotlin is you can use
backticks to name your methods or
classes as you like it wouldn't look
like it that's a little bit easier read
one of the best parts of this language
is its human readability and I know I
kind of jumped ahead before the
introduction of Kotlin part but this is
the reason why I thought I would jump in
the pool with it because there's lots of
different kinds of test frameworks
available for all different languages
but this is the first time I saw a
language built-in that can do this kind
of thing so anytime anything would
compile and I'd get errors it was as if
somebody wrote me a book or a tweet it
was very cool this is a hundred percent
human readable even someone who has no
idea what tests or class is is doing it
can they can read the method name and
understand the purpose right even more
if you've already some test cases or
scenarios written it can be easily
transformed into these unit tests by
copying and pasting titles of your test
scenarios and this includes Java the
great thing about Kotlin is it's
compatible with Java right so you can
write to us in Kotlin for code that
already exists pretty cool
and that brings me to the difference
between TDD and BDD or behavior driven
development too many anachronism oh my
gosh that is that is a one part of our
industry you gotta work on the jargon
behavior driven development is perhaps
the biggest source of confusion during
this part of the journey when it's
applied to automated testing BDD is a
set of best practices for writing great
tests BDD can and should be used
together with TDD and unit testing
methods so now I'm like oh so now I need
now I need to know this - all right
really behavior driven development
allows test focus on the desired
behavior or outcome it actually
hilariously decouples the naming of the
tests from what the actual functionality
is doing at the integration level that's
interesting
a common problem with poor unit test is
they rely too much on how the tested
function is implemented so that means
that if you update the function even
without changing the inputs and outputs
you must also update the test right this
is a problem because it makes you even
changes very tedious so behavior driven
development
addresses this problem by showing you
how to test so you should not have
supplementation but instead behavior
okay so with it unit testing gives you
the what test-driven development gives
you the when and behavior driven
development gives you the how okay
although you can use each individually
you really should combine them for the
best results because they complement
each other really well so now I kind of
had a little bit more of a framework for
how to think about TDD I had never
really messed with Kotlin before the
last time I had touched Android was
definitely in the java days and that was
back before a lot more work was done on
it right it's mobile has come a long way
it's been very interesting specifically
watching both iOS and Android changed
what their recommended
images are for building it's been pretty
cool did anybody use Java or Objective C
to do any of those yeah completely so
you know wouldn't you agree that both
platforms took a step in a much better
direction though like a little bit
easier to work with definitely much more
to stuff but there's still a lot of
power and using those other languages
and a lot of developers still do but it
was very cool to watch this language
grow and then get adopted by Google as
their official one for Android is really
neat so let's introduce Catlin and why I
think it's cool Kotlin is very concise
the less code you write the fewer
mistakes you make it's also very
expressive you can express whatever you
want in a shorter way because Java is
quite verbose right what I thought was
also interesting is when I first used
Java right I had done it after dotnet
after c-sharp right so I always thought
it was like hasti sharp is like just a
little bit more brief but they're very
similar in a lot of ways right have
their own runtimes they they're both
action oriented there's a lot in common
I just noticed that I could do some
things a little quicker a little less
for us in c-sharp and Kotlin is even
more so but it's much more compatible
with it directly it's also pragmatic
straight to the point without a lot of
writing it doesn't take a lot to get
something to build it's also typesafe
hooray remember the billion dollars
mistake it's really important that you
have something that you don't have to
think about too much I really appreciate
a good JavaScript developer because of
this because it's not a type say sorry
not a type safe language typescript is
but it's it's interesting that they
chose to go this way as well colin is
also functional so has anybody ever done
any sort of functional programming in
the room cool yes have you ever swapped
out trying between each of these in
Colin yeah yeah very cool
and what's neat is that functions and
properties are first class citizens in
Colin very cool it's also friendly so I
think I mentioned it before but
interoperability between Kotlin and Java
works almost perfectly it's very awesome
and it's human readable that was the
thing that drew me in the most because I
had a choice between doing Kotlin or
Swift on this project and I could have
you know chosen to work on the iOS or
Android implementation and I really
appreciated the way that Colin was put
together the best thing that apart from
improving readability it's also better
understood in the output of a result
when it fails you can see the readable
error much more clearly after something
like this so any questions very good so
this was an interesting part I remember
I think I mentioned that I worked a lot
on proof of concepts and the company I
worked with at the time they would give
me a couple of days maybe to come up
with something that they wanted to
impress a client with as please give us
a budget to do the real thing to do
production but they needed something in
their hands because most clients don't
know what they want till they see it and
they're like ok Heather we need this on
Friday it is currently Wednesday morning
you know and I'd be like oh ok like
usually they were some pressure for me
to like stay up all night or anything
but it was can you give us something
that we can just show them that means
you break a lot of traditional rules in
production code to deliver something
that quickly unless you are just that
speedy and it is possible to be that
speedy in a lot of ways but remember you
also have to deal with deployment and
the like if this was a cloud-based app
I'd also have to deal with you know
deployment to the cloud nice thing about
mobile is you can put it just directly
on someone's device and just hand it
over so they could look at it Febrary
you don't have to worry about deploying
it to the App Store's
at least not for proof of concepts after
working on this whole project and
delivering what we've delivered I can
tell you
pretty strongly that my opinion of using
TDD and proof of concepts is don't it's
- there's just too much to it it's not
that you that you can't do this well in
production code it's just it's a lot to
do in that short amount of time it's a
very verbose but if you have to do any
exploratory work you don't truly know
what's possible until you research it
and try some things out especially if
you're new to either the framework or
like Android in general it was you have
to kind of do a little bit of research
of us - what classes do what and you
have to know those things before you can
really write a red green refactor test
scenario you'd have to know a little bit
of it so that is a limitation that I saw
specifically using TDD with derivative
concepts is that you'd have to already
know a lot about what you're working in
in order for that to really go and not
that you can't write tests for a proof
of concept but if it's not production
code what is the value in it it either
works or it doesn't when you're
presenting it okay so that's just some
definitely my opinion but especially
when it comes to what clients want is
that most clients don't really want to
pay for tests extra tests to be done and
see almost nothing they would like to
see something okay so I think the answer
to this question really is where is the
value lie okay
it definitely lies in something that is
going to be maintained and created for
the long haul but not necessarily
something that just needs to be done
very quickly because you know if you've
got lots of time I mean you really know
how you're gonna do it maybe you can try
I mean if you have a lot of time to
present that proof of concept just go a
little bit later as you know TDD is
valuable as a tool you need to use it
when it fits and don't use it when it
doesn't which is also the same thing for
doing things and software development in
general how agile are you
what does agile mean to you guys how
small and iterative do you want to be
does that mean you have no planning
upfront these are questions that we ask
time if it works continue using it if it
doesn't work for you guys then don't
work then don't do that I know lots of
different groups they'll just say let's
just do have a brainstorming session for
several hours which by the way is
planning you know and see if we can
flush something out and go with it that
sounds like it's agile to me but to
other people they're like that's
technically more water fallish you know
semantics like do what works for you
that's really the most important thing
that I've learned is that when you want
to be valuable as a developer and you
want to deliver something pretty quickly
sometimes you have to adjust the
processes that you have and you have to
be willing to speak up to your
management team or the team you've got
around you to say you know what is it
just ask the question what is important
here is it important that we get that we
deliver something in this time or is it
important that we deliver a hundred
percent test coverage sometimes the
answer is both then that means you have
to decide how much of that code you can
give in that time right and nobody wants
to hear that they want to hear all of
the above
but remember something's got to give so
don't be afraid to be the one to be
realistic in that way okay let's do some
sort of a collaborative game shall we at
least yeah oh he says one or two of you
will hopefully do this I'm gonna go
ahead and give you some scenarios based
on the given win then okay given that
the state of the world is X when
something happens the state of the world
now looks like Y okay like given my bank
account is in credit and I made no
withdrawals recently when I attempt to
withdraw an amount less than my cards
limit then the withdrawal should
complete with out errors or warnings
which is what I always hope for every
time I buy a noble ticket all right I
have like please go through every time
but that's mostly because I'm out of the
country and I just never know it's gonna
any thing that's gonna get pinged or if
it's gonna go through a good trick that
prevents most of the accidental misuse
and the given when then is to use past
tense
forgiving clauses present tense for win
and future tense for then
that was helpful to me any anyways and
this makes it clear that given
statements are preconditions and
parameters and that the then statements
are post conditions and expectations so
and your application life cycle it needs
to be taken into consideration this is
very useful as specifically when you're
doing things like showing and hiding
screens and when they appear and when
they disappear so make given and then
passive they should describe values
rather than actions okay
make sure when is active it should
describe the action under the test and
try having only one wins statement for
each scenario remember we went from like
one function to four tests right I'm
gonna give you a case and you guys gonna
just let me know how many things we
could probably build from that right
okay as a user I want to be able to log
into the app once and not have to do it
again okay right so given what anybody
know yeah so given okay given the users
logged in when what okay so when app
launches okay or when like main
activities running okay that's fine
don't know what what user is still
logged in so that is you're checking a
pool for that right so we have now
written the condition of a test that
doesn't exist yet right so that means
all I'm gonna do is write it is just a
sign of bool and make it true that's the
test pass yes is that useful now that
means we have one test right that passes
but that doesn't actually do or really
really need it to do in order to fulfill
this this user story right that's just
one one of them right so we know that we
you need a bool that gives us an answer
so what's the next one given what
no this is what I had to go through by
the way it was like given what you might
have the same given by the way it might
be like yeah I know right this is okay
so given that this function yeah
so given that some function name okay
has received true or false
then what sure sure absolutely
or that's so that's one test right so
then we write an additional method that
takes in or at least checks that bool
and then does something so if the users
logging in for the first time that's one
test saying when the user logs in I want
you to change this bool to their logged
in when this user logs in I want to
store their information when the shoes
are like than that you see it adds one
and adds one so now that we are thinking
that's already for okay right okay so
now we have a negative test right when
the user is not logged in I cannot
launch the app right so this is just
this is all tied to just one user story
right and it's in my brain it's still
one function but really it's different
pieces of it okay so let's try a
different one as a user I don't want my
password to be shown when I type it
right yes
ah yes yes okay so you that was a very
good question by the way so your
question was what if there are
dependencies on the other test passing
there are not dependencies on the other
tests passing they individually are run
whether or not things need to be in
place in order for later tests you right
to pass is the point of the red green
refactor the idea is that you're writing
pieces of that test right now you just
need something to do this you're like
well that's not that useful I need to do
an additional step in order to write a
test that will be more useful right you
start with a smallest and then you
continue to go but they would are still
run independently you should be able to
hide all the other tests and run them
individually and have them still pass
does that make sense yeah I know so for
me it was very difficult because when I
started
I'm already 12 steps ahead thinking
about the next thing okay and the
practice for me was what is the first
thing that needs to happen or what is
the smallest thing that can happen and I
thought it was kind of silly even an
uncle Bob said in his interviews like
okay so I have to write all this stuff
and it's extra code and actually write
less production code than I do tests so
there's way more code in my des classes
then there is a reproduction code and
he's like yeah but that's a good thing
because you want it to be as small as
possible to do the least amount of work
and completely decoupled that was the
idea yes
I think that's probably accurate so that
was that was a good point so just to
repeat any dependencies maybe that you
would need should be referenced in the
given statement so like give and I my
users like then are given I do have this
password or I don't that indicates to
not just like the human eye but also as
you're building this what you should be
expecting so strange things started to
happen I started not wanting to write a
lot of tests which means I started to
want to do the simplest thing possible
and not make it complex at least in my
production code because it but I already
have four or five tests for just a basic
thing right and that was a good turning
point for me is that I realized that in
a way even though it's more work to
write tests it definitely made me not
want to write more production code okay
and I know that sounds strange but it
was smaller like our files were smaller
we actually ran a test against it just
to analyze to see and they were smaller
but yes
the point is your finger still typed
more when you do you do test-driven
development for sure there's no denying
that and so like it go ahead say that
again you can do this would be a unit
test just to do the functionality of
that was that your question
hmm
mm-hmm sure but it depends on the way
you've abstracted your patterns right so
if you're doing mvvm as an approach or
my presenter however you're doing it you
can right now I was just giving you an
example of yeah when this user does this
but the UI is separate you know from the
actual level of functionality that does
it right so you can write another one
for that right in this case because we
worked in a team we were just doing the
functionality layer we were just doing
the manager or the presenter work or the
view model if you will yeah but that's
that's a good point is that you can
write this like four different levels of
that application as well so I might not
really care what the UI is doing in this
layer but I might in the next yes and in
case three as a user I want to login to
the app to access the system okay to me
all of these seems like pretty simple
requests right Kotlin does a really good
job of making a lot of this easy but I
had to stop and think right I just stop
and think about how I do this
so now that you kind of had a little bit
of a taste of how much you have to break
it down let me show you what kind of
saved me a little bit okay I was able to
search online and an anonymous writer
otherwise I would credit them created
the five step method of easy TDD which I
am like glory hallelujah cuz right now
that's so much thinking about how to
write things down I need I need to be
able to automate this in my brain right
number one decide the inputs and outputs
so I'm like okay decide the input I need
I know that I'm gonna need this and I
know I'm gonna want that at the end we
start this process from a high level we
don't care about the implementation just
yet
we have the goal calculate password
strength you know to get to that goal we
usually need some inputs right
and then we get some output based on
them so when you normally start writing
code to get to some goal
you'd probably start with a function you
probably think of what data the function
needs to work and what kind of results
it will give back right we can start
this process by doing exactly that we
just won't write any code for it yet
okay so how would this work the input is
easy it just has to be the password
right the output is also easy it has to
be some value describing the strength of
the password right it's for a validator
to keep things simple let's say the
password is either strong or it isn't so
we can use a boolean value for the input
for the output okay
so input is password and then the output
is bull okay then I have to choose the
function signature right so now that we
know what data goes in and what comes
out we need to choose the function
signature so that is what the parameters
the function takes and whether it
returned something this step is again
very similar so what we've been doing
forever it just you kind of approach
writing code without TDD just like this
right before you can write any code for
a function you need to decide what all
this is so none of this is has deviated
from the traditional coding methods that
I've done but first of the parameters
what does our function need to work in
this case it's simple all it requires is
the password right we can do the whole
calculation based entirely on that value
and that value alone but what about the
return value simple since this is a
calculation we can return the result
directly right in some more complex
cases the return value might be a
promise or some sort of additional
change method but instead of returning a
value the function might take a callback
parameter or it might just not return
anything at all it could just be a void
right either way at this point we can
now decide what calling the function
would look like in code so now we
finally get to touch it tada okay now we
had written our first line of production
code hooray
okay cool next we decide on one aspect
of functionality we now know that the
goal the day
involved in the function signature right
in a non TDD workflow you jump into
writing code for the function now you
might already have some ideas on how
this would work right I know I do
I think Riley really rapidly we need to
check for this we need to check for that
we had to return value was affected by
this right this is how most people run
into trouble with TDD including your
surely because my head was filled it's
all these ideas on how to write the
function and but I'm not sure of exactly
how to lay out the code until you start
writing it like I wanted to I would love
I want to touch the protection code now
right
I just I'm visualizing it in my head so
instead of thinking of all the choices
let's focus on just one tiny thing for
now so what is the single simplest
possible behavior that we need to get a
tiny bit closer to our goal right so a
common problem is to try and tackle a
chunk of behavior that's really big
right because that's what makes me get
up in the morning what makes me code if
we think of password strength there's
ideas of different rules like special
characters and numbers password length
etc and of course it's hard to think of
a test that would cover every one of
those situations right so what is the
simplest possible step we can take to
make this function be a little closer to
the ultimate goal of validating a
password hey what would be the very
first line or two of code that I could
write if I both this function without
TDD all right what is the smallest
amount the very simplest rule for
password strength might be the empty
password right that's really easy so the
output should always be false when the
password is empty that's something you
can write and so thus I was able to
finally start adding my various
conditons cases I started with the
easiest one whether or not something's
null whether or not something's empty
that's usually how I was able to very
quickly just add some tests right in the
beginning and then I started thinking
about them as I went number four is that
you implement the test right the main
difference is that instead of focusing
on implementing the
we're focusing on how the function would
be called and what happens as a result
so that is that we're thinking about the
function and how it behaves under some
conditions so how the function behaves
is what we want to test once you start
testing behavior under some conditions
like time of day or whatever you know
testing becomes a lot easier because we
can look at behavior from the outside we
don't need to know the implementation if
we're just choosing behavior and that
blew my mind because I think in code but
this made me think like a client and
that broke my brain a little bit but the
good artifact from that is that it did
make me be a little bit closer to the
humanity of the project okay we decided
the function takes a password as its
only parameter okay
we also decided it returns a boolean to
indicate whether the password was strong
or not right we also chose that for an
empty password the result should always
be false to indicate an empty password
is weak all right implemented that
pretty easy and number five we finally
implemented the code so these are the
five steps that I was able to break down
and think about that really started me
to go because I'm I don't do well
without examples I need to know examples
of how to do things the problem is that
takes away creativity if I just look at
how an example of a red green refactor
test I will always think that way that
takes away almost all the creativity on
how I think about problems so all I will
only ever do it this way
so this this five steps kind of allowed
me to still kind of retake the creative
part of my brain because
implement code it's very
self-explanatory right we'll just add
the smallest amount of code that makes
the test pass right if we were to
continue developing the password
strength function all we do is just
repeat steps one through five or sorry
three through five yes yes three through
five that's correct and she was the next
tiny step to make step four at tests at
five on who might repeat that's all I
did and really we're already doing that
anyway without TDD we just didn't think
about it formally
so then it stopped feeling so foreign
right if you keep advancing in small
steps like this tdd some suddenly
becomes a lot easier yes you might end
up with several tests for a very small
amount of code but that's not a bad
thing okay so TDD kind of helps you in
this way to reduce the amount of useless
code you might otherwise write you're
not really sure if it really affects it
because you can give it a cursory glance
and have you ever done this where you've
asked another up here or perhaps the
senior above you to like look at it and
they see something right away you're
like you don't need to assign that to a
variable just return the result why are
you doing that this is an extra step it
does work but it's a waste of code why
are you doing that and this actually
prevents that from ever happening what
do you think about it because every line
of code you add is verified by a test so
you're not allowed to write production
code without a test it's both it's the
most wonderful and an infuriating
process I don't think I've ever been
through but it taught me a lot of
lessons about how quickly my brain skips
to the next exciting thing instead of
taking the steps in between I'd be
terrible at being able to program a
robot because if I just say okay you got
a walking out turn right and and left
yeah but what does it take to run what
does it take to walk what it takes a
step well what is a step like I have to
put my heel down first and then the
middle of my foot and then step on my
you know there's there's a lot of tiny
pieces to it but because we've had these
wonderful object-oriented programming
exist for so long we don't think that
way
we're like go run there TURN RIGHT
because we have extra functions that
just go do that for us so this kind of
allowed me to take a step back almost on
that robotic level which sounded really
tedious but it actually made me find
ways to make things even more efficient
than what the framework allowed me to do
you know that was that was an
interesting kind of take away so
speaking of takeaways let's talk about
some Q on shall we
if you do TV with Kotlin specifically it
will avoid over architecting right with
tightly focused coding work on
acceptance criteria right it had it only
is allowed to do things the acceptance
criteria tells you to do and where the
tests tell you to do it provides
confidence that those cascading code
changes are flagged by failing tests so
the moment you do something that changes
anything
it really does tell you what it loves
specifically about doing it in Kotlin is
because it adds a human readable style
of executable test phrasing that is
awesome
cuz I don't know about you but instead
of looking at that I mean I really look
at that much much better I know it's not
a lot of detail but this thing right
here probably saved me hours of
debugging just being able to read that
okay because when you're starting to be
in a large group of people every minute
is really important why live text meant
for robots information meant for humans
you know I for one would definitely go
for the second one but I know people who
would prefer the first you know that's
my fallible opinion anyway right so what
do you think yeah thank you very much
for listening to me today if you have
any more questions about the journey
that you two can go on to doing TDD as
Colin I'll be just outside thank you
very much
[Applause]